die letzten vier Jahre haben wir dr
Watson Videos in Räumen produziert die
eigentlich normale Wohnungen sein
sollten jetzt wird sich das aber ändern
wir ziehen um in ein richtiges Büro mit
über doppelt so viel Fläche und dazu
gehört ein neues Studio und auch ein
neues Doktor Watson Wheelies sein
[Applaus]
normalerweise machen wir keine Videos
die nichts konkret mit Wissenschaft zu
tun haben aber das hier ist gerade
einfach zu sparend und zu exciting dass
wir euch nicht davon erzählen und ich
habe noch einige Updates die ich euch in
diesem Video hier mitbringen möchte das
allerwichtigste ist erstmal es wird ein
neues Logo geben das alte dr Watson Logo
hat inzwischen ausgedient das ist jetzt
sieben Jahre alt und bei uns dazu
entschieden mein Gesicht als Logo zu
nehmen das heißt bei dem nächsten Upload
werdet ihr schon sehen es gibt ein
kleines neues Logo einfach damit ihr
bescheid wisst aber auch ganz ganz viele
andere Sachen werden sich jetzt ein
bisschen verändern noch mal ein bisschen
moderner ein bisschen snappiger werden
wir haben komplett neue Corporate
Identity aufgebaut mit neuen Animationen
neuen Statistiken neuen Grafiken und ich
freue mich schon sehr dass ihr das alles
sehen werdet und zwar nächsten Sonntag
ab heute in einer Woche kommt ein neues
Video online und zwar das größte dass
wir jemals gemacht haben die Wahrheit
über erneuerbare Energien vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch noch an die Wahrheit
über Elektroautos das wird ungefähr so
ähnlich nur noch aufwendiger mit noch
mehr Recherche deswegen hoffe ich sehr
dass ihr dann nächsten Sonntag sofort
dabei seid liked kommentiert und
irgendwie dem Algorithmus zeigt das ist
ein gutes Video damit das gepusht wird
weil da steckt so viel Arbeit drin in
fünf bis sechs dr Watson Videos ungefähr
außerdem ein kurzes Update diese
T-Shirts hier die James Web Teleskop
T-Shirts werden jetzt endlich
ausgeliefert die ersten von euch haben
sich schon bekommen und falls ihr sie
noch nicht bekommen habt dann wartet
vielleicht noch ein zwei Wochen ihr
solltet jetzt eigentlich jeden Tag eure
Versandbestätigung bekommen falls nicht
meldet euch gerne hier dann wird euch da
geholfen und schickt uns gerne Fotos von
euren T-Shirts macht selfies davon dann
veröffentlichen wir die auf Instagram
oder auf Twitter und ich freue mich
schon sehr zu sehen wie ihr alle diese
T-Shirts hier tragen ich freue mich vor
allem darauf zu sehen wie ich die ersten
Leute unten auf der Straße in the wild
mit diesen T-Shirts hier sehe ich bin
sehr happy damit es kann sehr gut bei
euch an und wir sind total glücklich
dass dieses T-Shirt auch so krass
nachgefragt wurde das haben sehr sehr
viele Leute bestellt und ich hoffe ihr
seid alle sehr glücklich mit diesem
T-Shirts
wahrscheinlich habt ihr es nicht so
wirklich mitbekommen aber in den letzten
Jahren haben wir immer mehr Leute dazu
bekommen wir sind inzwischen ein Team
von 13 Leuten die alle in unserem Büro
aktuell so ein bisschen eingepfercht
sind jeder Raum ist quasi ein
Durchgangsraum wenn man einen Kaffee
trinken muss dann muss man da rein wenn
man zu Toilette muss dann muss man durch
und deswegen sind sehr froh dass wir
jetzt endlich ein größeres Büro haben
dass sie wird zum Beispiel ein komplett
eigener Konferenzraum weil wir relativ
häufig Meetings haben wo wir Dinge
besprechen müssen und das muss aktuell
gemacht werden in einem Raum wo andere
Leute drin arbeiten auch das Essen wir
essen tatsächlich gerade in der
Redaktion was die Leute in der Redaktion
natürlich total nervt und deswegen bin
ich sehr sehr happy dass wir jetzt viel
viel mehr Räume haben haben einen
Konferenzraum wir haben einen eigenen
Produktionsraum einer eigenen
Redaktionsraum einen riesigen
postproduktionsraum das unsere größte
Abteilung wo Animationen entstehen wo
geschnitten wird wenn man doppelt so
großes Studio dass ich euch gleich
zeigen werde und jetzt ganz neu wir
haben eine eigene edit Suite also ein
ganzer Raum wo nur geschnitten wird
vielleicht mit einem Regisseur zusammen
wo man die Tür zu machen kann und seine
Ruhe hat für besonders große besonders
wichtige Projekte wie euch vielleicht
vorstellen könnt 300 Quadratmeter sind
relativ viel das sind so sechs bis acht
Wohnungen je nachdem wie groß eure
Wohnungen so sind hier ist also sehr
sehr viel stuff drin wir haben jetzt
hier nur ein Bruchteil aktuell stehen
das sind die Sachen die wir sowieso
schon hatten teilweise wir haben aber
auch neue Sachen gekauft zum Beispiel
diese großen Traversen hier wir haben
eine neue Kamera die wir gekauft haben
die jetzt in 6k filmt und all das muss
natürlich irgendwie bezahlt werden
deswegen kommt jetzt Werbung während ich
euch das Büro zeige
hey Cedric Star Trek oder Star Trek auf
jeden Fall Star Trek die Leute den Kanal
hier schon länger verfolgen wissen dass
ich auf jeden Fall Team Star Trek bin
und das liegt daran dass die Serie immer
super spannende philosophische Fragen
aufwirft und cooles hifi-technologien
wie beamen zeigt fun fact Star Trek hat
mich zu dem allerersten Video hier auf
dem Kanal inspiriert haben Maschinen ein
Bewusstsein ich weiß normalerweise sind
wir kein Gaming Kanal und Berichten
nicht über Spieler aber ich dachte mir
für Star Trek machen wir mal eine
Ausnahme Star Trek Fleet command ist ein
Forex Strategiespiel für Handys aber
auch für den PC Forex steht für explore
expand Exploit and text terminate du
beginnst also mit einer kleinen Basis
und muss dann deine Flotte immer weiter
vergrößern um das Universum von Star
Trek immer weiter zu erforschen und zu
beherrschen Fleet command gibt es schon
seit einigen Jahren wird aber ständig
mit neuen Updates versorgt und das
aktuellste Update jetzt gerade bringt
eine ganz besondere Mission mit ins
Spiel das coole daran ist ist dass du
die Geschichte von Deep Space Nine
nacherleben kannst und du kannst sogar
Charaktere wie Cisco Kira und O'Brien
aus der or anderen Serie rekrutieren
wenn Ihnen das Spiel ausprobieren wollt
dann klickt einfach auf den ersten Link
unten in der Videobeschreibung vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen euer Cedric und
jetzt bin ich zurück ins alte büromarea
deep space